I have a suggestion for Beto Arora today
Beto should leave the presidential
campaign go back to Texas and challenge
the other Texas senator Republican John
Cornyn for his seat in 2020 I'm gonna
make the case for you here if you
disagree with me okay don't tell me that
I'm an anti Beto shill in the primary
don't listen skip it all tell me which
of my facts are wrong or which don't
point to this being a good idea I'm
gonna build the case up for you here in
2016
Donald Trump won Texas over Hillary
Clinton by about 52 to 43 it was a
nine-point margin by which Donald Trump
defeated Hillary Clinton in Texas in
2016 in 2012 Mitt Romney defeated Barack
Obama in Texas by a margin of 16 meaning
Trump's margin in Texas in the last
presidential election was not nearly as
big as Mitt Romney's in 2012 and in 2008
even though as I'm sure you know Barack
Obama defeated John McCain in the
presidential election McCain also beat
Obama by a much larger margin than
Trump's margin and victory over Hillary
it was a 12 point margin of victory for
McCain / Obama in Texas in 2012 so for
starters number one in 2016 Texas was
closer in the presidential election than
it had been in a long time
in 2018 beto O'Rourke ran against Texas
senator Ted Cruz now Ted Cruz ended up
winning that a reelection campaign it
was very close 50 point 89 percent to 48
point 33 percent the margin of victory
for Ted Cruz over better or roark as the
incumbent Republican senator in Texas
was only about two and a half percentage
points this is a very slim margin for an
incumbent Republican senator in Texas
better or work then decided to take the
name recognition that he built to some
degree during his 2018 Senate run
against Ted Cruz and run for president
and unfortunately better or work is not
doing well in his presidential campaign
so we're putting up on the screen the
polling
for a variety of Democratic candidates
Beto's polling is the pink line which we
have signaled for you in the graphic and
you'll notice that beta was polling as
high as nearly 10 percent some months
ago and it's just been a steady and
consistent decline down to now averaging
only about three and a half percent in
national polls is better or orc in a
recent Iowa poll which is the first
twenty twenty caucus stayed Beddoes
polling only two percent
okay so Beto has fallen from some level
of grace we could say and the reality is
Beto is not going to be so impressive
once the upcoming democratic debates
start that he's going to regain anything
close to a real shot at being the
Democratic nominee however there's no
denying that Beto O'Rourke is more well
known today than he ever has been so
what better or work should do is leave
the presidential race gracefully I mean
participate in the first or second
debate next month since he's in them
he's qualified continue to raise his
name recognition a little bit but then
go back to Texas and run against the
other
Texas senator Republican John Cornyn
because as I told you in another story
today Donald Trump's favorability in
Texas right now is only plus three which
is very low for a Republican candidate
in the state of Texas the mood in
general is good for another run by
better O'Rourke in Texas and importantly
Cornyn is even less popular than Ted
Cruz in Texas there's a February 2019
which is four months old but it's still
relatively illuminating and the
favorability rating for John Cornyn is
lower in Texas now then Ted Cruz's was
when a better O'Rourke ran against him
in 2018 so this is a very strong way to
number one maybe turn a red seat blue
but also to cause the Republican Party
to have to invest a bunch of money in
defending John Cornyn seat beto has
until I believe it's early December to
file for the Senate election in Texas
Beto is not going to have any serious
impact
on this presidential race Beto could
immediately have an impact in Texas he
could force the Texas Republican Party
and even the National Republican
National Committee to a minimum spend a
ton of money defending John Cornyn seat
maybe John Cornyn can even be defeated
in Texas and when we look at the 20/20
math for the Senate and we realize the
math just doesn't look good for
Democrats because of which third of the
Senate seats are up for re-election
we're assuming that John Cornyn
definitely gets reelected Beto would
have a shot people don't love John
Cornyn the mood in Texas is almost as
liberal as it has ever been if not as
liberal as it has ever been
Texas isn't thrilled with Trump Cornyn
has been mostly a trump guy this is a
real opportunity beto should get out
gracefully I get it participate in a
debate or two so you can raise more
money keep your name in the news to some
degree but then use the name recognition
and go run against the Republican
senator in Texas where he has a much
better shot than he has of becoming the
Democratic presidential nominee what do
you think okay if you disagree with any
of the facts that I'm using to come to
this conclusion tell me where I'm wrong
on the facts if you agree with the facts
but disagree with my conclusion I also
want to hear from you if you're just
going to send out homonyms skip it just
not worth it we don't have time for it
we've got real business to deal with
here make sure you're following the
David Pakman show on instagram at david
pakman show make sure you're following
me at David Pakman as well I am thrilled
to tell you that today's episode is
sponsored in part by Blink accom slash
Pakman blinka is a really unique service
for your phone tablet and web browser
and it is incredibly useful for people
like me who love books and learning but
are busy blinka stakes the best and most
popular non-fiction books and condenses
them into 15-minute audiobooks I'm sure
that if you're like me you have a very
long list of books that you've been
meaning to read
you only have so many hours in the day
and that's why blink astiz so amazing
they take the most important information
the themes the insights from each book
and they distill it into a 15 minute
audio book that you can listen to in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blankets our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink is comm
slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the
description I have listened to blinka
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
go to blink is comm slash Pakman that's
B Li NK is t.com /pa ke ma n